[Music]
kevin's in houston hey dude can you hear
me sure what's up
um so
i'm calling in uh i've been in a little
bit of a pickle trying to decide what
loans to pay off and whether or not the
pull out of investment accounts that
were set up for me when i was younger
my buddy brandon recommended uh actually
just calling on your show which is why
i'm here now
i've got uh right now i've got
actually when i look at it total quite a
bit of debt um
95 000 total um 13 of that is a car
seven of that is federal student loans
42 is private student loans
and i'm paying just a little bit over
minimum on most of those i round up to
the next hundred
but i am well what's the other 40 grand
oh sorry 40 is a private student loans
now you said 32 you said 32 is student
loans seven was student loans the 13 was
a car
oh shoot i'm mixing them up 32 is a
rental property that i own it's a house
that i don't live in that i rent out oh
okay 42 is private student loans okay
now i'm there now i'm the 95. okay yeah
i'm caught up with you and how much
money you got in the bank from all these
different things um
so
between my checking and what i consider
my emergency savings i've got
ten thousand
um nine thousand that's sitting in kind
of investment accounts
some of that was set up before i was
even
able to talk
and then four thousand i had earmarked
for some travel that i was trying to
budget and save ahead for
okay so i got like i guess what i'd call
like 23 000 that's
scare quotes available
although some of that's the emergency
fund yeah so it's like i've got like 20
000 and like do i
um i currently make about 64 000 a year
base salary i do get overtime and some
bonuses which i usually
throw into savings okay
uh the
your your friends sent you into a bear
trap
[Laughter]
so i because i could tell by talking to
you that you've you're not super
familiar with everything we do um and so
i'm going to be super gentle okay
is that okay i have read total money
makeover believe it or not i feel like
i'm definitely half-assed everything
okay well you definitely have yeah
without a doubt okay then i'm not going
to be as gentle okay
i'm i'm going to love you well kevin i'm
going to love you well um so here's the
thing
you've got what you've got to decide is
are you going to keep doing what you've
been doing
you have to decide it right now but you
do need to make that decision
because you know
as you said half-ass doing it doesn't
work
it's you know being a half-butt
gives you a half a butt i mean it's just
that you're not gonna get there
so the thing is
if you study the data which we have done
over the years with what millionaires do
people that become millionaires starting
from nothing and you have the potential
to do that
um the first thing they do is they clean
up their debt
because
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income and so once you make that
decision and you say all right
i want to become wealthy and the
shortest distance between where i am and
wealth is to get rid of the debt then
debt becomes the enemy once you
put that set of assumptions in your
brain do you agree with that
yeah do you agree with that
okay
if you if you if you say the shortest
way to something is x then x becomes the
thing right
if the shortest way to lose weight is
drink more water then drink more water
becomes the thing
you follow me yes absolutely okay so
you either decide that what we teach is
right or you decide it's not right and
you go find a different way of doing
your life and that's okay i'm not mad at
you for that
but millions and millions of people have
followed this exact plan
and we've got data to back it up and
we've got lots and lots of case studies
to back it up that it works
so
given that yeah you're not traveling
anywhere you're freaking broke so your
little travel fund goes on your debt
and you list your debts smallest to
largest you take six extra jobs you
don't see the inside of a restaurant
unless you're working there and don't
talk to me about vacations you're
working all the time you are a broke guy
and you need to clean this freaking mess
up and this is how i talked to myself
when i got out dude so i'm gonna talk to
you this way because i love you and i
want you to win
all right
so you list your death smallest largest
and you attack them with a vengeance
what's this rental worth
um so it's a single family house 50 it's
about fifty thousand dollars in value
good sell it
sell it
it's a crappy little house it's a cash
loan property it's a crappy little house
it's a lot of hassle in your life you're
not cash flowing 100 bucks when all the
smoke clears and the repairs on it i own
real estate there's no margin in this
deal you got a 20 or 30 equity position
and there's no margin in it
and it's not it's not it's not the
answer to your wealth building i want
you to get real estate later and i want
you to pay cash for it but right now
it's a distraction and it costs you
money when the smoke clears are very
very close to it it certainly costs you
your time and you're making a dollar an
hour screwing with this thing so you
need to get rid of it list your debts
smallest to largest and get in attack
mode and you could be debt free in like
14 to 18 months if you do what i'm
talking about and you follow the total
money makeover but you got to decide if
you want to do that or not not everybody
does
les brown
christina les brown the great motivator
said people change their lives when they
finally say i've had it
i've had it i'm not doing this anymore
yeah and i think it's great that he
called in because he's in a great spot
to make that change right now while 95k
in debt sounds super intimidating when
you break down a situation it's like he
can do this pretty quickly if he sells
the rental if he pulls some of those
investments from when he was a kid that
you know he could go towards that debt
he's in a great spot but like you said
he's just got to make that decision and
go all in gazelle intense yeah i forgot
about that other 20 grand so we sell the
rental it gets rid of 30 of the 95. i
got 42 i got seven i got 13 and i got
1923
in
the account i got to hold a thousand for
baby step one so you got 22 to throw to
this so the car's paid off the student
loans are paid off the only thing left
is the 42 in student loans yup
and he can do this
and whatever whatever you make on the
rental you throw at the student loans
too
and you clean this freaking mess up dude
now you're out of that he's out of debt
in nine months
if he gets to gazelle intensity
but if you keep screwing around with it
half button it
it does this doesn't work it just
doesn't work if you have buddy you got
to go you're going to get a different
system if you're going to half but and i
appreciate that he was willing to admit
that right
yeah me too i mean because i mean the
thing is the the definition of insanity
the 12-step persay is continuing to do
the same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result so you can
keep doing what you've been doing in
your marriage relationship and you're
going to have the exact same marriage
relationship it could be good
if you're if you've got a good one keep
doing it right
you know you could keep doing this
parenting stuff
but i remember mom when we would be
raising cain as little hillbillies
running out of the house she would say
and the worm has turned and we didn't
even know what that meant except the
beatings were about to begin
and but that was shakespeare turns out
who knew mom knew shakespeare but um you
know but what that meant was enough
this craziness stops
and you got to do that to yourself you
got to go enough this craziness stops
i'm not going to keep baking a cake
wondering why it's chocolate when i used
a chocolate recipe
change the recipe
you know and that that when they do that
christina life changes absolutely and
that's why we say that money it's 80
behavior 20 head knowledge it's about
changing your behavior the way you think
around money and actually shifting
things exactly